[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show my
former home of new york city is getting
ready to become the first urban area in
the united states to adopt what is
called congestion pricing now congestion
pricing is actually relatively common in
europe the idea is it's a fee for
drivers who are entering some designated
part of the city could be what's that
called the city center it could be the
immediate urban area whatever the whole
point of it is you want to dissuade
people from driving in you want to
generate money oftentimes to improve
public transit which in New York City
specifically the the subway system is
what New York City wants to fund
improvements for and a poll done by
Quinnipiac University found that 54% of
New Yorkers oppose this change in policy
and transportation policy experts were
given these numbers and they were asked
is this like an expected amount of
opposition to a policy like this and
apparently the answer is yes in general
when a congestion pricing has been
adopted in other cities half or more of
the population that lives in the city is
against the policy but then once it's
put in place it very quickly will shift
opinion and sometimes very significantly
in favor of that new reality because it
actually does work and this policy in
New York will go into effect in 2021 and
all sorts of different groups and
interest groups are trying to get
exemptions which could be more than $10
per day half the half the city says they
don't like it but what we know from
experience Pat is that these work they
improve public transit systems they
reduce congestion and for the most part
people end up being pretty happy that
cities do this yeah and I certainly
don't doubt any of that I don't doubt
that over time it's going to become more
popular that you'll be able to fund
public transportation with the money
that you raise but I guess there is a
case to be made that New Yorkers they're
already hit with a bunch of fees when
trying to bring their car into the city
like I think if you try to get into
Manhattan depending on whichever
whatever
bridgie takes to get there is about an
eight dollar fee or a ten dollar fee so
if you have not at that amount of money
is not true through Brooklyn Bridge
Brooklyn to Manhattan free okay so maybe
that's just the one one way and okay if
you told to get in and then you have to
pay a toll to get to the center of the
city maybe certain cost you 20 bucks the
the spirit of what you're saying is
completely correct which is for the
people who can least afford additional
fees those are often the people who are
coming from further away or from places
where you do have to pay a fee or take
some outrageously circuitous route I
don't want people who are for
cost-of-living reasons already living
really far from the city but commuting
into the city for work for it to be even
more expensive for them to commute in
and they may be coming from places that
are less well-connected on public
transit and I think for that you've got
to look at exemptions based on income I
think there's no way around it because I
don't want to penalize people who are
least able to pay yeah it's a sticky
situation for sure because public
transportation isn't all that well
funded it's not that great especially in
the United States I don't know about New
York specifically but if you you know
you're not able to rely so much on
public transportation because it's just
inefficient and you have to take your
car in you're putting this bad spot
all's but on the other hand if we're
able to use this money raised to help
public transportation maybe that will
encourage more people to take it in and
we can sort of fix the problems that we
have with that yeah it was initially
it's gonna be tough the only problem is
again if you're commuting everywhere in
New York City is expensive like okay I
guess if you go to Brownsville Brooklyn
it's still cheaper but it's still
surprisingly expensive to even live
there most people who are for financial
reasons commuting in from outside the
city are living in places that are
outside the city which means that
funding New York City public transit is
not going to improve the options that
they have available they might be
dependent on commuter rails New Jersey
Transit er or something else but big
picture I've experienced congestion
pricing in some European cities and
it really I mean it's it's noticeably
more convenient to get around cities as
a tourist of course if you're trying to
just get to work I can understand how it
would be a pain in the ass but it's
noticeably more convenient and I tend to
think that this is a an interesting
policy that in New York may work out a
little differently given the size of New
York but we'll see what happens in 2021
or later if it ends up being delayed or
postponed a Texas bartender who served a
man alcohol the night that he shot his
estranged wife and seven others two
years ago has been charged with Kimen
criminal negligence and this is a very
interesting legal case Lindsey glass was
arrested in Texas last month accused of
violating a state alcohol law because
she served alcohol to an intoxicated or
insane person and what authorities are
claiming is that she should have known
to stop serving Spencer hight because he
appeared drunk and armed and she now
faces a year in jail a $500 fine or both
which is a really great example of those
instances you point out Pat where the
prison time is completely out of sync
with it like if you ask me would you
rather spend a year in jail or pay 500
bucks I know which one I'm choosing yeah
because there's no job that's going to
pay you only $500 for the course of an
entire year you can make that money
somewhat easily in that year so the
problematic thing the thing here for me
Pat is that the law as it says is
selling alcohol to an intoxicated or
insane person or insane implies that a
bartender should be able to make
assessments about sanity in situations
where people are ordering alcohol at a
bar and that alone seems completely
unrealistic yeah and it may even be
unrealistic to say that they should know
the level of intoxication of the patron
because you don't know how much they had
to drink coming in and some people you
know they wear that on their sleeve when
they're too intoxicated they'll be
stumbling around but other people just
have a high tolerance and that doesn't
mean that they're not drunk yeah and so
I don't know the direction that that
this is going to take as it is the law
as it's written in Texas is sort of
weird because of this issue of
somebody who's apparently insane it's
gonna be a legal fight and this could
have significant precedent-setting power
because there have many states and I
have friends who are bartenders in
Massachusetts have code that says what
they need to do in terms of cutting
people off but taking it a step further
you know we've heard about this applied
to drunk driving situations somebody is
served too much they get out into a car
they drive drunk and they get into an
accident what if any responsibility does
the bartender have going out and killing
someone is much more difficult to even
link to the alcohol right like no matter
how much most people drink they're not
going to go out and shoot people and
therefore linking it to the being served
alcohol to me is significantly more
dubious yeah and I guess he was playing
with a knife on the bar table but that
could have happened after he was done
ordering drinks and was ready to check
out so you know I don't really know the
the series of events and the timing of
events there what about the case that it
should be the business that's held
responsible and not the individual
employees so like if something happens
like this or a drunk driving incident
maybe you whack the business with a
significant fine but you don't go after
the individual employees maybe the
business after getting hit with a fine
and knowing that the bartender did
something wrong would decide to fire the
bartender but it just rubs me the wrong
way that you're going to consider prison
time for the bartender over this it does
also rubbed me the wrong way and of
course going after the business raises
other questions most bars are just small
businesses that I just you know being
willing and able and actually choosing
to go out and kill people is something
that requires a lot going on within that
person's mind and to start holding
public businesses even partially
responsible for people grabbing guns and
shooting others it I don't like pointing
to slippery slopes when I don't think
that they really are but I would have
some serious concerns about that in this
case yes shooting others for sure
because also that's just so rare it's
you know sort of an anomaly but what
about someone drinks too much of the bar
and then goes out and drunk drives and
then gets into a horrible accident
I mean who are the business be I'm on
yeah it's tough to decide where to draw
the line I think yeah it definitely is
and we'll see ultimately where this case
comes out and whether she might end up
having the devastating penalty of having
to cut a check for 500 bucks or might
have to spend an entire year in jail
it's Jail if it's under 18 months is
that right now I don't remember I know
it's short term stay but I don't know
exactly the how much time yeah and it
may even vary bye-bye state students at
in a Rhode Island school district who
owe money on their school lunch accounts
will have the only option of a sunflower
butter and jelly sandwich until they're
able to pay their balances according to
an announcement from the district over
the weekend this is so to me it looks
like Warwick but is it pronounced
Warwick like the second W is silent I'm
not even sure I always thought it was
Warwick Rhode Island but I'm known to
say things wrong hello who knows
Warwick public schools which has 9,000
pre-k through 12th grade students says
this goes into effect on May 13th quote
if money is owed on a paid free or
reduced lunch account I don't know how
you could owe money on a free lunch
account but that's maybe a story for a
different day if money is owed on a paid
free or reduced lunch account a son
butter and jelly sandwich will be given
as the lunch choice until the balance
owed is paid in full or a payment plan
is set up this is partially because
public schools are mandated to provide
lunches to students but it is not a hot
lunch that is required I feel really
mixed about this Pat because okay if
people get free lunch they get free
lunch I don't even know how that has
anything to do with this if you qualify
for a reduced lunch or you don't your
parents are supposed to pay either the
reduced price or the full price and
there has to be some system in place for
making sure that people aren't taking
advantage of the system it's a you know
ledger it's its input and output revenue
and expenditure you got to pay for the
lunch somebody's got to pay for lunch
fine but punishing the kid particularly
in a way that's very visually
stigmatizing like my guess is that if
given the option most
kids aren't choosing the sunflower
butter and jelly sandwich they're
choosing something else so it creates a
situation where other students look
around and they see who has the jelly
sandwich and it further stigmatizes them
which is a big problem with with poverty
assuming that some of the reasoning here
is poverty and not parents who are just
forgetting so I hesitate to punish kids
in ways that will stigmatize them
although I understand that the schools
got to get his money I don't know
yeah the schools that I went to growing
up most of the lunch tickets that we had
were yellow so if you were just paying
the standard price you had a yellow
lunch ticket but if you had a reduced
priced lunch then you had like a green
ticket if the elementary school had it
was and it might have been the opposite
I think it was Green was the full price
and yellow was reduced and then there
was one for free or something like that
so even from a distance you could tell
who had which lunch you know yeah and it
makes them totally more susceptible to
bullying I don't like it at all people
say that there's no such thing as a free
lunch I wish that there could be I don't
know how much that would cost the
taxpayers and local jurisdictions but I
think it may be worth it especially if
you talk about the price of the school
lunch is only like what three four
dollars I don't know what they are now
exactly but can that really add up to a
lot of money over the course of a year
for a small town I think it can I mean I
think in proportion to the size of the
town's budget and the city budget that
spending now the other thing is I think
that what the reason the price is only
like three or four bucks is because it's
already subsidized so I think the real
cost is probably more so you're already
kind of chopping off part of that fee I
don't know I don't know what the
solution here is but it is it is really
sad when you see these situations where
kids who just want lunch are penalized
and stigmatized for reasons that have
nothing to do with them either their
parent didn't pay the bill or their
parent doesn't have the money either way
it's not the kids fault and we
perpetuate these stigmatization cycles
by doing this but by the way what is
that noise Pat do you hear that noise
what I don't know what what noise that
is a very strange noise I'm not hearing
anything it could be interference we
have maybe something on your end yeah I
don't know make one more point about the
school lunch lease yeah okay so
regardless of how old you are
K through 12 you get the sunflower
butter and jelly sandwich that's
probably not enough to feed high school
students like if you have like a
200-pound 17-year old football player
that's not gonna get him through the
rest of the day and also if you're not
well-fed if you're not well nourished
you're probably not going to perform
well in school and that can create a
vicious cycle where maybe you yourself
as you become another also enter stage
of poverty we don't want you're getting
you're basically getting all of the
things that lead to someone having a bad
life outcome you're stigmatizing them
for not having the money for lunch
you're creating a situation where they
may be hungry while trying to learn math
which we know makes it very very
difficult to learn math it's a disaster
all around and unfortunately I don't
have the answer but I'm open to hearing
ideas from people in the audience that
does it for today new show new bonus
show coming up tonight the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]